For a year now my CEA has gone up about 10 points per month but this last month it dropped 10 points.
I was very curious to know if this is a good sign or can fluctuate like this.
Well, your CEA, so CEA is a tour walker test.
So that's not something you would normally do.
This person must have a diagnosis of cancer and their monetary, their cancer using tour markers.
If your CEA has gone up 10 points per month for the last, for the last,
or it doesn't save for the rest, but that would be a definitely concern for me.
And you'd want to investigate further what is causing that.
If it's dropped 10 points this last month, of course that would be something that's encouraging.
However, there's different reasons why a person's tour markers could go up and down.
Other than the growth or the diminished growth of a cancer.
So if a cancer is be destroyed, if a person's using chemotherapy, your tour markers can go up.
So if you have a high degree of cancer cell, lysis can raise your tour markers.
So you'd want to be aware if you're doing chemotherapy.
If you're not doing chemotherapy, my CEA is going up.
And you should trigger you to look at other things.
Remember, there's no perfect lab, there's no perfect test.
But every lab, every test gives you clues.
So the clue that you that you bleed from elevated tour markers is that the possibility of cancer growth.
So you'd want to look at a, you know, talk to an oncologist, your oncologist and see if there's a PET scan or CT scan or MRI that's in order.
So you can monitor growth plus you look at other blood markers too.
Hopefully you're doing a CBC to make sure that you don't have the DMEA, which is probably the most common thing that you're going to see a CBC with a cancer patient, especially if cancer is growing.
It's going to be a worsening of an DMEA.
Secondly, on a complete metabolic panel, you're going to want to look for your alkaline phosphatase and your calcium levels.
Make sure those are not going up because that could suggest metastasis to bone or albumin total protein levels going down.
That could succeed some prominent points as well.
So I want to look at other things as well.
Any time you look at a test number, you look at it in light of other tests and other objective findings, as well as other subjective findings.
I've had patients where two of our workers are going up, but they feel better than they've ever felt in their life.
And they're just up to worry about it and they seem to just be fine.
And then when they do go in for other objective testing, there's nothing else that's showing.
So even doing an alternative approach can cause cell lysis of the cancer cells and can raise two of our workers.
So yeah, there's other things you want to look at before you can have a complete answer to that question.